hello again you know I'm gonna say here
we go again
Sony have revealed the six free games
we'll be receiving as PS Plus
subscribers for the month of June 2018
as always these games will be available
from around midday on the first Tuesday
of the month this time around that's
June 5th ready let's do this let's start
with the offerings on ps4 and up first
is the exceptional XCOM 2 set 20 years
after we lost the events of the first
game we now must overthrow our alien /
rulers if you don't know XCOM it's a
turn-based tactical role-playing game
with devastating risk/reward elements
let me break it down a little more each
of the characters you are given can be
customized before being sent into battle
renaming characters after your best
friend's dog can be soul destroying when
they die in combat because that's it
perma death the game continues without
them each successful mission they
undertake leads to incremental
improvements to their character and
loadout leading to even more risk/reward
in the following mission but don't worry
unless you're playing on Ironman mode
you can save before each mission over
about 30 hours you'll win back the world
and adapt to higher-level
enemies in multiple mission types and
guess what it's procedurally generated
so you'll never truly know the map
layout the reviews range from seven out
of ten to nines and above from GameSpot
Game Informer and IGN I quite like the
art style but I know it doesn't look
fantastic to everyone but I beg you give
this one a try next up is trials fusion
from back in 2014 it's a platformer
motocross racing game which is
ridiculously fun and frustratingly
challenging in places each bike has
different weight and power attributes
which means you'll need to master many
vehicles to truly beat this game the
physics although rkd hold a level of
realism which may force you to fixate on
one bike before trying others the stunt
bike flips around like a gymnast whereas
the heavier bikes require accurate
weight distribution you'll be told with
this one you'll be ecstatic by making a
checkpoint and then moments later you'll
be devastated by an error of judgment I
think what I'm saying is there's more
under the hood than a typical racing
side scroller trials fusion received
solid eights across the review bar
over on the ps3 is the solid
third-person tactical shooter Tom
Clancy's Ghost Recon Future Soldier oh
my god that's a freaking mouthful it's
essentially a cover shooter with the
ability to switch to first-person view
one of the greatest additions in future
Soldier in my eyes was the adaptive
camouflage allowing for impressive
stealth gameplay if you played other
Ghost Recon games the stink shot is here
allowing you and your squad mates to
synchronize shooting people in the face
lovely the campaign can be played
cooperatively too which makes it a far
better experience back in 2012
future Soldier averaged between seven
and a half and eight out of ten I'll be
honest here if the ps4 had backwards
compatibility I'd be downloading this
one in an instant
such a shame game number four is Zombie
driver HD complete edition which as the
name suggests is a vehicular zombie
combat game from a top-down perspective
your job is to rescue civilians collect
upgrades and slaughtered countless
zombies there's eight vehicles to choose
from with each one possessing slightly
different attributes like top speed
armor and number of seats needed to save
more civilians zombie driver is a
different take on the zombie apocalypse
genre gonna try it I'd love to know in
the comments let's quickly jump over to
the unloved Vita and first up is atomic
ninjas which is a multiplayer action
platformer although there is a
single-player component it's all about
co-op or rather counter co-op as you
attempt to subtly push your friend into
a trap or two there are eight ninjas to
choose from one of which is a good old
zombie they get everywhere those little
buggers and finally game number six is
squares which looks as fun as watching
paint dry but what it lacks in any
visual appeal at all it tries to make up
in puzzles mainly ones that test your
reflexes and speed of reactions maybe
something to dry on your commute to work
or school what do you think okay it's a
bit of a hit and miss month but I'm
delighted to get another try at XCOM 2
in which my main character captain
buttmunch
died after 40 missions I never really
got over that one
oh and transfusion looks like a blast
too but my opinion means diddly-squat
what are you downloading this month let
me know your thoughts in the comments
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade spin a
pleasure I'll see you next time oh I
miss you Captain Bob munch